I looked at an article earlier on that
identified the Divergence in Rotten
Tomatoes uh critics and audience scores
and they have never been further apart
on average according to the data science
that was done by this so as an example
critics loved an audience's loathed Star
Wars The Last Jedi which was 49 divided
and audiences loved and critics loathed
Venom which was 51 divided in 2022 the
gap between audience and critic scores
on Rotten Tomatoes has become bigger
than ever audiences have given the top
10 movies on average score more than 19
points higher than critics by far the
biggest difference this Century the only
two of this year's 10 movies where
audiences and critics are even close was
top gun Maverick and the Batman what do
you think that says about the state of
modern movies
I think they're not making people happy
I think people are watching them and
they're coming away fundamentally
unsatisfied and the critics that I guess
they used to kind of trust because they
would generally agree on movies because
I think the actual quality of films was
better but 10 20 years ago uh now
they're diverging because they're
beginning to realize that uh these
critics that they used to trust are
basically just paid to give positive
reviews and you know it's in their
interest to be positive because it
allows them to keep getting access to
film premieres to getting all those
little lovely goody baskets and stuff
that Studios send you if you're a
professional critic uh and you know that
that's what they go on
um and so there's now this realization
of wow these people are really full of
crap and I can't trust their opinions on
anything uh and so yeah I'm glad that
it's finally happened I'm glad people
have woken up to like really how rotten
that entire industry is I think Rotten
Tomatoes is a good term for it
there is a situation though when critics
are poorly reviewing films
and the audience is reviewing a film
well so this isn't a case of the critics
cozying up to some studio what's going
on there
I think in those cases it may be a case
of ideological
um persuasion in that uh generally in
the movie World surely not who would
have thought
I think generally when that happens it's
a case of a movie which uh doesn't align
with the current uh ideology of
Hollywood and um audiences generally lap
that up because man most people are just
they're not left-wing they're not
right-wing they're just in the middle
and when they go to the movies they just
want to be entertained that's all they
want and when they get a movie that
gives them that uh they generally love
it but then the critics
they don't love it because it's not it's
not spouting the the ideology that
they've been taught that they have to uh
that they have to agree with and then
they have to promote at any cost and so
yeah that's generally when that happens
it's interesting right because movies
for a long time were a good vehicle that
could be used to put forward an
important social movement narrative it
was a way of communicating to the masses
in a entertaining in subtle way that
this is something that you might have to
think about but it does seem more and
more flagrant more and more mask off
less subtle and more almost uh like
being flagellated like being whipped by
the film
I I yeah I don't get it in a lot of
cases I don't get why people would want
to watch them you know it's uh what can
I liken it to
um
yeah I mean I suppose the classic
example is something like the Last Jedi
from Star Wars uh if you if you go watch
that it's like you know I guess I just
have to accept now that all white men
are just awful at everything and they
suck and that's just that myself
included you know so I should just hang
my head and shame for the rest of my
life uh yeah it's it's a strange
um
it's a strange sort of uh
offering that they're giving us now
where we're gonna actively
hate you as a as a art form you know
we're going to make our business to make
you feel awful about yourself and if you
dare to push back on that and uh and
reject the offering that we're giving
you uh then we get we will label you as
a bigot or uh reactionary or whatever
you know stupid term we label people
with these days uh there's no actual
engagement with criticism anymore and
it's uh it's a frustrating thing but
then again I feel like more and more
people are just kind of seeing through
that now they've like you say the mask
is off and
um it's becoming very obvious how biased
and you know uh tilted in One Direction
is uh I think you know that that TV show
that they kit that came out recently
Velma I don't know if you've heard about
that but it's it's like this weird uh
attempt to reboot the whole Scooby-Doo
thing that we watched when we were kids
you know the kids cartoon
um no it's told from the point of view
of Velma and it's all about like every
character has been race swapped
everyone's gay now uh the the only
character that's been kept as a white
guy is Fred who's now the butt of every
single joke he's an idiot uh he can't do
anything for himself all that stuff and
it's like it's like a parody
of uh of the kind of uh messages that
they were putting out you know a few
years ago uh but it's so over the top
and ridiculous that it's like every peop
every person from every side of the
argument is hating on it I just think
it's really funny
well I mean if you were a well-meaning
moderate left liberal person and this
was the popular media that was supposed
to represent your side I would be so
ridiculously embarrassed I I
it's worse to have your point of view or
your side of the aisle be misrepresented
by this like
woke It's Like A Parasite that's just
embodied what used to be quite a loved
institution Scooby-Doo was legendary
right when we were kids Scooby-Doo was
pretty I think it was just it was it was
just innocent fun you know and I think
that's that's what people took it as and
now it's like
God it from what I've heard because I
only watched the first couple episodes
and I was done but even then it's like
it's got 15 year old girls in the shower
room you know like full-on nude it's got
like
um Velma who's like again the same age
in a strip club it's like what are you
what are you showing us what are you
doing with this
and it's like I I have to question the
mindset of the people who have written
this and created it and the executives
that signed off on it this has got to be
borderline you know this is really
distasteful stuff now and it's like this
all came from a a goofy kids TV show
from the 1970s about like a bunch of
bunch of college students that went
around solving Mysteries like why why
are you doing this
well we've seen the same thing with
She-Hulk right that was sort of
pretty mask off in terms of how that got
repurposed and the worst one that I've
seen recently was uh Doctor Strange two
I watched that on a plane before anybody
on YouTube had had a chance to do a
summary explaining why I shouldn't watch
it even on a plane and I got sideswiped
by uh yeah I watched a little bit of
She-Hulk and then bailed out but I
watched all of Doctor Strange too
because I was literally trapped in a tin
box flying at 35 000 feet but uh yeah
you'll watch pretty much anything when
you're on a long-haul flight wouldn't
you correct
um but I mean it was it it's the same
tenor with that right it's I don't know
it's just not it doesn't feel subtle
anymore there's no progression to the
characters especially if they're female
or from a minority and this is something
that I really enjoyed talking to Baggage
Claim about which is that it patronizes
women because it basically makes them
out to be incapable of ever dealing with
any challenge they can't overcome
anything they are perfect as they are I
mean there's a moment in Doctor Strange
too where zombie Benedict Cumberbatch
goes back in time to tell America Chavez
the South American daughter of two women
that she just needed to believe in
herself all along
that is the running theme when it comes
to these female characters and it's such
an unhealthy message to send to people
um you know even like take an r a
personal opinions out of the equation
that it's like you know trying to make
out that women are just perfect at
everything which you know we're all
human none of us are perfect
um it's teaching people that you
shouldn't need to strive to improve
yourself you shouldn't need to struggle
and when you come across uh challenges
or adversity the rest of the world just
needs to accept that you're amazing the
way you are imagine if people took that
to heart and tried to take that lesson
out into the world and apply it to their
lives it would be disastrous for them
they would just get hit with like
failure after failure uh you know
it it's it used to be such a much more
inspiring message that movies gave you
about that the power of self-improvement
of of rising to challenges and
struggling uh and you know maybe failing
and making mistakes but learning from
them and becoming better as a result
um that was a great thing to teach
people because that's how you progress
in life you know
um so yeah to try and do that it's not
only is it patronizing but it's really
counterproductive for people
especially given that a lot of the
lessons that people learn about how to
exist in the world come from popular
media you know especially given that
these are movies that ostensibly are
supposed to help people who perhaps
don't come from the perfect sort of
background maybe they haven't had an
amazing parental household giving them
all of the worldly wisdom that they
should do to be able to navigate through
okay so you are going to in some regard
like as a movie studio be a surrogate
parent almost or like a sage or a grand
parent in some regard to pass down these
are some kind of
Timeless truths that you can hold on to
and the Timeless truth is if you're a 15
year old mixed race investigator coming
out of high school with a talking dog
for a friend
get naked in the shower and go to a
strip club
that seems to be the lesson what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]
foreign